What I eat in a day as a mom who eats an ancestral diet
and as someone who avoids seed oils,
artificial sugars, dyes,
and preservatives at all costs.
I start my morning off with a coffee
using organic beans to caffeinate
with the chemical free Swiss water process
and then have a small bowl of probiotic cottage cheese
with passion fruit from my vine.
At 8:00am I get to making sourdough pizza using my sourdough,
freshly milled whole grain flour,
salt and water. While that rests,
I make myself two fried eggs for my pasture raised chickens out back.
My chickens get an organic corn free,
soy free grain mix. At two PM
I prepare the batter for a loaf of chocolate chip pumpkin bread
using 24 hour fermented buckwheat and iron corn flour.
While this bakes for one hour,
I make some pate
using pasture raised chicken livers from a nearby farm
along with garlic, butter,
Rosemary for my bush, raw cream and salt.
This pate is absolutely delicious
and incredibly nutritious for everybody
from babies to adult. I save and reuse all my glass jars and free
small servings of pate for a later day.
The pumpkin bread comes out of the oven
just as I get back in the house from picking the kids up from school,
and shortly thereafter I shape the pizzas
allowing them to do their final rise before dinner.
At five thirty PM I prepare the pizzas by carefully placing the dough
Onto a hot pizza stove
pairing with pasture raised raw cheese and all beef pepperonis,
then baking for 7 minutes on the outside grill until sizzling.
Salad is quick and simple with an olive oil and vinegar dressing.
I transferred the hot pizza to a wooden board
and slice it using a pizza cutter.
This is the best pizza in the world,
hands down. For dessert
we enjoyed a piece of chocolate chip pumpkin bread with butter.